another deadline missed in the battle
over covid secrets
and came the reason why
the cabinet office announced that it's
to launch a legal battle with the
official covert inquiry over Boris
Johnson's WhatsApp messages Diaries and
notebooks
and the government has challenged the
former PM's claim that he's handed over
all his material in full and unedited
claiming it only covers the period from
May 2021 when he acquired a new phone
sources here tell me the government only
really had two choices agree to the
inquiry's demands to hand over
everything in full or go to court
a legal battle between a government and
a major public inquiry is not
unprecedented but it's pretty unusual
in a letter to the inquiry a government
lawyer said the cabinet office has today
sought leave to bring a judicial review
we do so with regret and with an
assurance that we will continue to
cooperate fully with the inquiry
individuals Junior officials current and
former ministers and departments should
not be required to provide material
that's irrelevant to the inquiry's work
Rishi sunak attending a summit of
European leaders in Moldova defended the
government's defiant stance the
government's cooperated thoroughly with
the inquiry today handing over tens of
thousands of of documents and we will
continue to comply of course with the
law and cooperate with the inquiry we're
confident in our position but are
carefully considering next steps
next steps will now plunge the
government into a bitter legal battle
against the inquiries chair retired
appeal court judge baroness Hallett
bereaved families who lost loved ones
during the pandemic claim the
government's refusal to hand over all
the material inquiry wants is an insult
what are they hiding what is it that you
know if they keep saying they keep
talking about transparency and helping
out and you know wanting to learn from
their mistakes and everything else but
why is it had to go this far again to
get these WhatsApp messages to get the
notes to get everything that we need as
families
to get this inquiry going properly
after a day immersed in international
Affairs abroad Mr sunac flew home to
face accusations of a covered cover-up